Christian says of course Christian
that's that's good one to start out with
Christian if you're poor or middle-class
Dave Ramsey provides the worst financial
advice guys credit is a good thing
debt can be a good thing too Thank You
Christian
thank you this worked so well for so
many so I'm sure your opinion is popular
we know it's popular among broke people
Karl says this has all been said before
but Dave Ramsey's quote arguments
against credit cards drive me up a wall
well good
it's a walls a good place for some
people Cassie says contrary to popular
opinion I'm not I'm just not a Dave
Ramsey fan well the popular opinion is
that you are a Dave Ramsey fan what are
you saying he takes the fun out of
everything
[Laughter]
I tell you to be a grown-up oh there you
go
clue says clue I don't have a Twitter
he'll get a clue could be a Twitter
handle that would be a good one if I
gave legal advice of the same caliber as
Dave Ramsey's financial advice I'd be
disbarred there you go Melanie says we
got background music oh this is good
Melanie says even financial gurus like
Dave Ramsey are geared toward people who
have money everything costs more when
you're poor every single thing Oh
Melanie's poor oh brother give me a
break
call the wambulance Savannah says Dave's
Ramsey's voice annoys me there I said it
without shocking that's what you know
it's these really mean enough James I
mean they're just kind of mid-level mean
they're actually getting harder to find
it's harder to find mean ones yeah I
guess people are starting to warm up to
you know they're not warming up to me
it's just totally dying for
Twitter's just dying there yeah yeah an
Instagram you're not allowed to be mean
on Instagram it's you know it's all for
unicorns and rainbows and skittles and
you just can't that's why I can't do
Instagram Twitter for mean people I mean
it's come on the ones I love though are
these the students the high school
students are going through if you didn't
know 38% almost four out of ten now high
schools in America teach Dave Ramsey's
personal finance curriculum which
involves me being on video along with
some of the other ramsey personalities
anthony o'neal rachel cruz Chris Hogue
and others are being on the videos
teaching this and so the students are
sitting in class now I have to tell you
full disclaimer where I sitting in class
and forced to watch this old bald guy on
the TV instead of my teacher actually
teaching I would be pissed I would be
the smarty smart aleck snarky even
though I'm very proud of our curriculum
and you should all watch it and do
everything I say to do because then
you'll be rich and not broken dumb but I
seriously work because I was a smart
ankle can you imagine that in high
school and I was the kid always getting
in trouble for talking can you imagine
that and I would have been the kid there
was no such thing as a cellphone much
less a smart cell phone in your hand in
a classroom when I was there I mean we
had to shoot the dinosaurs out to have a
place to sit but if I had been there I
would have been tweeting crap talking
smack just because I've been bored
because I'm just about 3/4 a TD so these
but these aren't even that bad these
student ones aren't that bad Austin one
of those high school students Dave
Ramsey videos will instantly ruin your
day
there you go instantly ray says Dave
Ramsey's voice is so obnoxious it makes
me ashamed to be southern regional hate
their regional hate
my goodness that's pretty good ray Oh
Ray's back again this is the same ring
yes yet to get she had two good ones go
right spelled like our AE spelled like
the Star Wars ray right okay Dave Ramsey
more like Gordon Ramsay because he makes
me want to scream oh I saw somebody
tweet the other day something is like if
you are a ramsey and your own
broadcaster you have to be obnoxious
because both Dave and Gordon are or
something like that that was pretty good
we're a little bit different kind of
obnoxious but we are both obnoxious it's
it's a Scottish heritage you know it's
just that's what it is so there you go
those are okay and we're not the best
mean tweets we've ever had some of them
are just straight-up hilarious keep in
mind that some of them I can't print on
there cuz they're just a little too you
put them on there and just have a bleep
okay I don't read the word but we could
just say bleep how do we do that next
time yeah we'll have to bring out the
because some of these people they you
know always wonder if they kiss their
mother with that mouth you know I mean
seriously that's because I mean people
start dropping f-bombs I just block them
I mean I blocked like ten or fifteen
thousand people on Twitter that's why I
don't get any mean tweets cuz I blocked
everybody that's what it is all these
people whose parents are cousins but
yeah I mean you're gonna start dropping
f-bombs in a tweet line I'm done I'm
over hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]